hello freak [ __ ] well from doing Fear
Factor for six years I got a PhD in
questionable humans most of them were
wonderful people but every show I had to
deal with one person like what [ __ ]
Jesus Christ yeah so how did you do you
did that for a while and then they
brought it back they brought it back for
seven episodes but only six aired
because the seventh one we had people
drink come ah that killed the show
second time I was actually happy got
killed the second time because it was a
mistake
and [ __ ] I should have done it but it
was a bunch old friends like the people
that were producing it were good friends
and it was the opportunity to work with
them and it was a shitload of money it
was like I just got talked into it was
like come on how to be fun like oh you
talk about the whole experience
I thought you meant the particular
episode well no no another particular
episode I can [ __ ] believe it when
they said that's what were they were
supposed to do I went with what human or
from
mule mule come well that's not so bad
we actually discussed this yesterday
oddly enough with Eliza
nothing to cover yeah I can't believe
it's coming up two days in a row but
that happens sometimes like subjects
come in waves and it's not even if I
bring them up for whatever reason they
come in waves
I didn't mean to force you into bringing
up that subject again well the other
problem with the second season of Fear
Factor and I could say this now because
it didn't happen is I was worried we're
gonna kill somebody I was really worried
it's like it seemed too dangerous like
they were ramping up the stunts and they
were making things like way more
spectacular and you're just taking
bigger chances and there was a lot of
downtime in between stunts there's a lot
of preparation there was a lot of like
checks and balances and they they really
wanted to make sure that everything was
tested and double tested and they really
mapped it out well but it was still
there were some hair-raising things he's
[ __ ] people had to do maybe fear was
too far maybe it should have been like
mildly uncomfortable factor where you
put people like in mildly uncomfortable
situations like hey I want you to go
over and talk to that woman she seems
kind of attractive there I mean and so
it's kind of a mildly uncomfortable and
they you know no one's gonna die no
one's gonna leave mind if she kills you
there there's um they're doing a new one
with Ludacris it's kind of that way
there's a new Fear Factor and Ludacris
the rapper
yeah host all right and like some of the
fears like forgetting your cell phone
somewhere like for like right isn't it
something stupid like that and they
don't have to eat anything gross mmm
which was this is really dumped and keep
that out because that was one of the
most popular parts of the original
series that was gigantic like the eating
gross [ __ ] part that's huge III have to
be honest with you that was the I I
couldn't watch that that was the hard
part for I don't I hear ya you know it
was hard for me to watch somebody do
something like because I wouldn't eat it
or drink it and I don't want to watch
somebody else do that but that's yeah
I'm with you I mean I wouldn't have want
well that's not true
I watched somebody sent me a clip of
steve-o with a gas mask on and I tweeted
it some guy farting into a tube and it
goes right in the steve-o face and he
threw up into the mask and I laughed so
hard that i retweeted it and you send it
to me
it's actually quite rude of him but it
was in response to iliza shlesinger his
appearance yesterday cast well look at
this look this guy's get a fart into
this tube and that the tube goes right
into steve-o's face look at this he
farts and steve-o blah
I liked it I almost threw up right there
I almost threw up I'd like to bring like
revive from the dead like Edgar Allan
Poe or Mark Twain and put him in a time
machine and bring him to now and go all
the stuff you did was Mike really cool
check out what we're doing now show them
that video
well the video back then had a cell
phone camera giving up on poetry like
all this Raven stuff nobody's buying
these these blackbird poems
does anybody have like a gas mask
yeah a fat guy departed too
[Applause]
[Music]